first of all thank you for clicking on
my face you keep me going on here that
as a fact i love you and second per
usual i do want to thank the sponsor of
this video this video is brought to you
by satisfy the original creator of the
asymmetric grip for the nintendo switch
if you have a nintendo switch one of the
cool things about it is you can be like
bane and be like
the playing fighting games on the switch
on the go was always so brutal it's too
narrow you don't have good grip with the
thumb stick so they sent me this i
tested this out i was like yeah
absolutely you get better thumb grips to
put over the analog pads you get a
better grip overall i can actually play
fighting games on the go on the switch
without wrist cramps also they have a
great elite case it's big enough to hold
your switch with the grip attached comes
with a shoulder strap it's a satchel
indiana jones had a satchel and there's
a huge sale going on right now at
satisfy.com all grips and bundles are up
to 50 off so click the link below use my
promo code jeremy5 to get an extra 5 off
of that because jeremy 5 is alive thank
you once again to satisfy for sponsoring
this video i do appreciate it game on my
friends
game on
[Music]
so venom let there be carnage is the
sequel to venom in this time that's
right he's fighting garnet as we saw in
the mid credits scene in the last movie
woody harrelson plays cletus cassidy he
got himself a haircut it's a way of
saying they
he lost the sideshow bobwig now venom
and carnage are going to fight an
elementary school me as well as junior
high me high school me me my 20s me and
my 30s me of any age bracket has been
waiting for this and
okay
it's it's complex it's not that
complicated it should be very simple i
mean it's venom versus carnage how how
on earth can you mess this up it's the
easiest layup ever which granted when
venom and carnage fight in this movie in
the last act i was thoroughly
entertained what to do leading up to
that final act what to fill the first
two acts with well pretty much what they
did in the first movie only thing is at
this point it seems kind of redundant at
the end of the first movie you know it's
like all right venom lethal protector
why do i think that because at the end
of the movie he was the lethal protector
and he ate a dude's brain which is like
all right great we're moving forward
with that because they've gotten to know
each other you can still have the banter
but lethal protector right no because
eddie brock is such a good dude he's
like no you can't eat people's brains
that's what villains do and i'm a good
guy and so a lot of this movie is a lot
of the tension between venom who wants
to eat brains and eddie brock who
doesn't want him to eat brains and there
we go tug of war granted some of the
dialogue cracks me up because tom
hardy's so good of course tom hardy's
gonna be great what do you think he's
gonna suck [ __ ] out of here he's not
gonna suck tom hardy's great arguing
with nothing which is a voice in the
character's head he was great in the
first movie doing that he's great in
this movie doing that he's absurdly
entertaining also venom when venom is
saying stuff and talking [ __ ] that no
one else can hear it is amusing and they
save their f-bomb card yes yes as being
a pg-13 movie they get one of those and
they use it very well again it cracked
me up but the bummer is i didn't want to
see grumpy old men but really it's
grumpy old parasite didn't need it it's
not something that's sprinkled into the
movie it's the basis of the movie it's
this tug of war over who's going to
control the body and then venom gets
pissed off and goes to a rave it gets
really weird and it shouldn't be it
should be so simple it's like all right
venom the lethal protector he's out
there being a vigilante maybe he's
trying to hide that from his ex no venom
at a rave that's what we needed to see i
just
i never thought that i was never like
you know what i could go for
totally i don't know it's like someone
out there is afraid to have a hero out
there who eats bad guys brains or
something it's
it's fine which actually speaks to the
rating and the accuracy of the character
for these venom movies i feel like as
long as the venom movies are pg-13 venom
will never fully be venom he won't be
the venom people have wanted to see
on screen since the 90s and yeah part of
the bummer is it is pg-13 which means
when carnage is out there killing anyone
it's he's making cars blow up or he's
strangling people you know it's just
like i've read novels with carnage that
are way more graphic woody harrelson was
great as cletus cassidy it's just i wish
they did his character better as all you
know the whole oh cletus cassidy cares
about his girlfriend i didn't care about
that also some of the edits and fades
were weird i don't know if it's because
they're trying to hide the fact that
there was an entire scene in there that
was cut out the movie's about 90 minutes
long maybe they did cut it short and
maybe they're trying to hide it some of
it seemed a little chopping from
experience i've seen that happen when a
longer movie is cut down to be a shorter
movie but long movie short movie doesn't
really matter if you know what to do
with the characters i just don't feel
they did i feel like they knew where the
end game was going it's all right venom
and carnage need to fight but they
didn't know how to get the two there in
a way that was actually pretty
interesting it's like they looked
backwards and they were like well that
worked in the first movie let's do it
more here i gave the first movie a bit
of [ __ ] because i felt like that oscorp
wannabe organization you know that
science company and the generic villain
i felt like they held the movie back
however i feel like the first movie is a
better movie there is a big credit scene
that was really good stay for that it
leaves you you leave the theater with a
good feeling the rest of the movie just
disappointed me also this is nitpick
territory but i've already done the
review now carnage's voice felt off to
me i felt like his voice was too low i
felt like his voice should have been
higher with more voices in there like it
was 10 high voices or something just
make him sound a bit crazier he sounded
more like juggernaut from deadpool 2.
benefit of the doubt though which is
funny about this rating i uh i've had to
go both ways i've had all right let's
watch the movie again with some drinks
i'm like it's worse this movie might be
better as in a better time if you're
drunk yeah now it's a park you i will
eat your face yeah i've been told worse
i don't know real talk here if hype is
the joy killer maybe looking forward to
something for that long just makes
something destined to fail
i don't know
but i don't think the movie measured up
right so venom let there be carnage have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you